[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going to
take a look at scaling up
our miniature grappling hook
using some PVC,
hanger wire, and rubber tubing.
This thing can shoot up to 30 feet.
[Music]
You may remember the tiny desktop
grappling hook that we built a while ago.
Today, we're going to try and scale
that up into something a little larger.
We're going to have a hook
a little over a foot long,
and we're going to build the whole thing
out of PVC and some rubber tube,
and build a grappling hook
that will launch way farther away.
Here's what we've got in mind.
We'll build a simple frame out of PVC,
and attach our rubber hose.
Our grappling hook will be made
out of a dowel and some hanger wire,
and we should be able to
launch that towing a string 30 feet away.
To get started, we're going to
need some hanger wire, a dowel,
couple different pieces of PVC,
and some rubber surgical tubing.
First thing we want to do
is build the grappling hook itself,
and that is going to be made out of
some hanger wire and a piece of dowel.
We can cut our dowel off
at 1 foot long if it's too long to start,
and we want to start with our
hanger wire as straight as we can.
So let's cut it off near the neck,
and then just straighten
out all of the wire.
[Music]
We now need to bend this wire
into our grappling hook shape,
and we want three prongs that the top.
It's really good at grabbing
stuff with three.
So we're going to start by giving
ourself a little bit of extra wire
that will attach to the shaft of the stick,
and then we'll start bending
in those hooks shapes.
[Music]
Our wire comes up.
It goes out for one spike,
out for a second spike,
out for a third spike,
and then comes back down.
It's got a little bit of extra wire
on here so we can trim that off.
Now, of course, this isn't
holding itself together very well.
It doesn't look much
like a grappling hook.
So let's modify it.
We're going to use some thin bailing wire.
Wrap that tightly around parts of it,
and then bend the hooks
into the shape that we want.
[Music]
If you really wanted extra strength
on your hook, you could double this up.
Cut the same pieces
of wire out of a hanger,
make it into the same shape,
attach it on top of this,
and just go over all of it with
bailing wire to really reinforce it.
I kind of like the single version.
It's a little bit lighter weight.
Still does a pretty good job.
Now, let's cut off that one
foot length from our dowel.
[Music]
To attach our wire hook
onto the top of this dowel,
we're now going to sand the sides down,
so it becomes a sort of tapered point.
[Music]
The wedge will fit in between
the two wires, which will bend to fit
along the sides of the dowel,
and then attach the whole thing using
more wire, and some tightly wound tape.
When the wire is pulled tight, it really
starts to bite into the wood a little
bit, which gives it a pretty secure grip.
[Music]
Now, to hold the wire in place,
and just to make it a little nicer
to hold onto, I've had times where
I've picked stuff up with this wire
on it, and ended up stabbing my finger.
We're going to use some
electrical tape to cover that all.
Electrical tape is also really nice
because as it stretches,
it does a very good job
of conforming perfectly
to what you're wrapping it around.
With that, the grappling hook
itself is now assembled,
and it's time to start building the launcher.
We've got some 1/2 inch PVC
and some 3/4 inch PVC.
Most of this is going to be 3/4 inch PVC
with just a little piece of the 1/2 inch.
To start off, let's cut a piece of our
1/2 inch PVC, about 3 inches long.
[Music]
Next, we want to cut a piece from our
3/4 inch PVC that's about 18 inches long.
[Music]
Our smaller 1/2 inch piece of PVC is
going to be attached near the end
of our 18 inch piece of 3/4 inch PVC.
This piece here is going to be a guide.
The grappling hook will thread down
through there, and it will keep it aimed
the direction we want as it launches out.
To attach it, there's a few different
things we're going to do,
and we're going to try
and make it pretty sturdy.
But it is important to remember
that this smaller piece is actually
not going to have any pressure put on it.
The elastic band will be attached
to the bigger piece of pipe,
as will the trigger,
as will pretty much everything.
So while the grappling hook is
going to be guided by this small rod,
if it's not super well attached,
it shouldn't make much difference
because nothing's going to push it off.
Even though it's not super important
that it's attached really well,
I do want to make a nice connection.
So first, I'm going to sand
down both sides a little bit,
so we have a nice flat joining
rather than the two curved
surfaces that we have right now.
Not bad.
Now, we're going to use just
a little bit of some PVC glue
attach those pieces together.
And then, in what is probably overkill,
we're also going to use some duct tape.
[Music]
Now, that is on there, probably much
more securely than we need it to be,
but better too much than too little.
Our surgical tubing is going to take
the place of what we used a rubber band
for with our miniature
grappling hook build.
It's a lot the same thing.
It's rubber and it's very stretchy,
and it's pretty strong stuff.
So we're going to attach that on
to here, and that's going to act
as the propulsion for our grappling hook.
Let's cut off a piece of our
tubing about 1 foot long.
We want that to loop behind
our support piece here,
and we want it to be attached to the top,
and we're just going to use
a zip tie to hold it in place there.
[Music]
Take our hook.
put it onto our rubber.
[Music]
Launching.
With the miniature grappling hook
launcher, we used a clothes pin
to hold the hook and the rubber
band back in place before we fired.
A single clothespin would not have
nearly the power to hold this back.
This rubber is far too stiff,
and has a lot more spring to it
than a single rubber band.
So it a clothespin's not going to do it.
So we're going to have
to build our own mechanism,
and we are going to make it similar
to a clothes pin, but modified slightly.
This is going to be our
substitute clothespin piece.
We'll cut a notch into the
bottom of the grappling hook
that can be gripped onto by this
portion of the wood down here,
and then we'll drill a hole into it
to act as a hinge point right about there.
Let's cut this out.
[Music]
Here's how our trigger
mechanism will work.
The band will be behind the
grappling hook, pushing it forward.
When we push down on the back
of this lever here,
it should get shot out.
We're going to use some
more hanger wire to attach
our clothespin piece to the PVC.
[Music]
Alright.
Let's see how our
trigger mechanism is working.
It's now attached
with a piece of hanger wire.
Let's test this outside.
[Music]
Whoo.
That's a good launch.
Of course, it won't launch quite as
far once there's a cord attached to it,
because it will have extra weight,
and friction that it has to overcome.
We're going to be using this nylon
string as the cord that attaches
to our grappling hook,
and we need a way to make
that spool off really nicely.
So, what we're going to do is take
this plastic cone inside this thread,
and use that as a spool
to wrap our cord around.
[Music]
We're going to want the spool
for our thread to rest kind of below
where it's launching out of,
and so, we need to build more frame,
and while we're doing that,
we're also going to build
sort of a shoulder rest for this thing
so we can hold on to it, have it pressed
up against our shoulder as we fire,
make it look a little bit more professional.
[Music]
Let's start with a T connection,
and then we'll go down
just enough to have a handle.
[Music]
Turn the corner there.
Let's see.
Let's get a piece, maybe, 10 inches long?
[Music]
That'll be a good spot.
And then we need a piece to back
this up enough that it's
pressed up against our shoulder.
[Music]
Another small piece, and just one more
elbow to give it a sort of rounded edge.
Attaching our spool to our piece of PVC.
I don't I want this to
be permanently attached.
I want this to be removable.
So what we're going to do is drill
a hole through the cone-shaped piece,
and the PVC pipe that's just
wide enough to fit this nail in,
and that nail will work as a linchpin
that keep the cone in place
when we want it there,
but we can easily remove it.
[Music]
Let's take down the point of our
nail just a little bit with a file,
because we don't need it so sharp.
That's better.
Much less likely to stab ourselves.
Now, let's take our nylon string,
measure out about 30 or 35 feet of it.
Attach one end to our grappling hook,
and the other end onto our cone.
[Music]
Drill another small hole into our cone.
This hole is just wide enough
that we can fit the string through.
[Music]
Fit that through, and add a knot.
And then, in addition to the knot,
we'll use a piece of tape just to hold
it flat down in place on the inside.
Really, the knot is what's
going to hold it in place,
but tape will just keep
the string where we want it.
If we want, we can just carefully
wrap the cord around the cone,
trying to keep it as close together,
and neat as possible, and that will work.
But there is a faster way.
Power.
I'm going to take this forstner bit,
set that down inside the cone,
fit the drill over that
until it's flush with the cone.
Tighten it on.
And the forstner bit will help provide
a little bit of grip down inside the cone.
And now...
[Music]
We've got a cord on our grappling hook,
so I think we need to test this out again.
Let's take it outside.
[Music]
Not bad.
One little thing you may notice
is that I had to hold this down.
The pressure from it trying to escape
was enough that as soon as I let go,
it fired, and that's not what we want.
So what we're going to do is take
a little bit more of this rubber tubing,
and we're going to attach
that around the trigger piece.
So it holds itself pressed down.
However, we didn't add that yet
because we now want to glue
all this together more permanently,
and paint it,
and I didn't want to have to cut
that rubber off, and then reattach it.
Time for some paint.
[Music]
Random fact: Grappling hooks are
a tool used by combat engineers.
After launching the hook
forward, they set off the trip
wires by pulling the hook back.
[Music]
I think we are in business.
Let's give this thing a few more tests,
including seeing what
we can grab with it.
[Music]
Three. Two. One.
It's basically a perfect shot.
[Music]
It's so much easier than just walking
over and grabbing the bucket.
The grappling hook gun
souped up to a larger size,
and don't worry, we're not done yet.
We are planing the scale this up even
more to the point where we can shoot
a functional grappling hook
that can hold our weight,
and climb the rope after it.
Guys, that's not all.
There's always more to see
here at The King of Random.
The box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box will show you what YouTube
thinks you should be watching next,
and if you aren't subscribed
to the channel yet,
hit this bomb in the middle,
and that way,
you'll never miss on any videos.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.